Shadowing, uh, of the Mini Stories,
which we have in all of our
languages, is something that I'm
going to do more of in the new year.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today,
I want to talk about goals for 2022,
but not in terms of my language goals,
but in terms of my activity goals.
And I mentioned that in the video that
I did earlier on my language goals.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
So I told you that I was going to
continue focusing on Arabic and Persian.
Uh, I might dabble a bit in Turkish, but
if we do launch Punjabi or some other
other South, or at least Indian, uh,
languages at LingQ, I will try to get
a bit of a sense of that language as
well as Tagalog, because we have a lot
of Punjabi speakers and Filipinos in
Vancouver, whether they speak, whether
they're native speakers of Tagalog or
not, I don't know, but I think most people
in the Philippines do speak Tagalog.
So I'll get my jollies
surprising them, say.
So those are language goals.
Now activity goals, uh, one of the
things that I want to do in the
new year is I want to read more.
I look back to my sort of Chinese
learning, uh, experience and, uh, I
did a lot of reading, more reading
than I'm doing now in my Arabic and
Persian because I had less audio.
So now I can sort of
say, okay, I'm listening.
I listened to something.
I picked it up.
I listened to half an hour while
preparing breakfast and cleaning
up or I listened to it in the car.
So I've done my thing.
Uh, actually, when I was
learning Chinese, I read a lot.
I read a lot and reading is powerful.
So I've said in the new year,
I'm going to read more and I can
read at LingQ in sentence mode.
And I can hear each sentence if
it's timestamped or I can use the
five-second rewind to, uh, to make sure
I've got the audio for that sentence.
But to some extent I'm cheating
because I'm listening to it
at the same time and it...
reading in, uh, Arabic
and Persian is difficult.
But I'm going to force myself to do
more reading where I don't listen so
that I'm forcing myself to try to rely
on my ability to read the language.
So that's one of my goals, do more
reading and I definitely would recommend
people that don't neglect your reading.
Reading is a powerful way for your
brain to get used to the language.
That's number one.
Number two, I am going
to do more shadowing.
I've started...
I mentioned shadowing in a previous video.
I've never been a big fan of shadowing uh,
partly because a lot of my listening is
listening to things, you know, whether it
be politics or economics, things where I'm
trying to understand what they're saying,
and if I shadow, then it confuses me and
I can't really hear what their saying.
But what I have discovered is that
our Mini Stories are ideal for
shadowing because inevitably...
shadowing by the way, is when
you listen to something and you
try to speak at the same time.
It's not a pause where
you repeat what you heard.
It's actually trying to imitate
what you hear simultaneously.
And I just find that that's, if I'm
listening to something that I'm genuinely
interested in, I find that very difficult
to do, and I quickly stop doing it.
But I said to myself, I'm going
to give this another chance.
So I tried it with different kinds
of material, and I find that with
the Mini Stories, it's great because
the Mini Stories are simpler.
I know the stories, there's so
much repetition that if I miss a
word in the first point of view of
the story, I'll pick it up in the
second point of view or I'll pick
it up in the questions and answers.
So it lends itself to a shadowing.
Second of all, I find that as I listen to
these mini stories, which I've listened
to many times, sometimes I lose focus.
And so even if I listen to it another
time and another time, I'm not
gaining anything because I'm kind
of skipping over the same parts that
I...that I skipped over the last time.
Now I'm forcing myself to actually
say what I hear and it forces me
to focus in, and I notice things
that I didn't notice before.
And so, and I enjoy it now.
So now for example, I was just on my
nordic track, you know, cross country
ski exercising thing that I have at home.
And I was listening to my mini stories in
Levantine Arabic, and I enjoy doing it.
It's a challenge.
It just, it's a challenge to try to
shadow with what you're listening to.
Uh, there's words there that
I noticed that I don't know.
So now I'm motivated to go and
read them again in the story.
And so I think that the shadowing of
the Mini Stories uh, which we have in
all of our languages, is something that
I'm going to do more of in the new year.
So more reading, more shadowing
and perhaps a little more
flashcarding of phrases.
I, I'm not convinced that flashcarding
words is all that useful, but with
phrases, key phrases to focus in on
those phrases that will help me speak
Arabic and Persian a little bit better.
So there, you have it, a bit of a, of a
sense of, um, some of my, uh, language
activity goals for the new year.
And I'll leave you the video
that I did on shadowing.
And, uh, also another one.
Uh, the one I did about my language goals.
Thank you for listening.